[Musik]
er ist ein kurzer nachrichten überblick
von uns aus der heute redaktion guten
abend in allen die anzahl der
neuinfektionen in deutschland bewegt
sich weiter und deutlich nach unten es
gibt fortschritte beim impfen aber und
das haben wir in dieser pandemie ja
bereits mehrfach erlebt es gibt neue
sorgen der bundesgesundheitsminister
warnt heute vor den gefahren durch die
sehr ansteckende delta variante des
virus weltweit ist sie bereits in mehr
als 80 ländern nachgewiesen vor allem in
großbritannien hat sie sich rasend
schnell durchgesetzt
mehr als 90 prozent aller neuinfektionen
macht die mutation dort aus inzwischen
ist sie europaweit auf dem vormarsch
christiane hübscher inzwischen ist jeder
zweite deutsche mindestens einmal
geimpft fast jeder dritte schon
vollständig ob das impf temporeichen
wird um die delta variante in schach zu
halten dass er unklar so
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen
im moment liegt der anteil hierzulande
bei 6 prozent aller neuinfektionen
die frage wird im übrigen nicht sein ob
delta die dominante variante auch in
deutschland und in kontinentaleuropa
wird sondern eher die frage wann und
unter welchen bedingungen in
großbritannien zeigt sich die delta
mutationen ist deutlich ansteckender
gegen ihre ausbreitung helfe nur
schneller impfen sagte rki chef wieland
daten aus großbritannien zeigen zwar
dass die impfung von biontech und
astrazeneca sehr gut vor schweren
verläufen durch delta schützen
das gilt aber eben nur für vollständig
geimpften draußen ohne drinnen mit maske
dazu weiter viel testen dann könne es
laut spahn und will er ein guter sommer
werden
trotz des wettlaufs gegen neue
mutationen in moskau steigen die
infektionszahlen immens an hier soll
sogar die medizinische routine
versorgung für nicht geimpfte
eingeschränkt werden drastische
maßnahmen auch in portugal die
hauptstadt lissabon ist seit dem
nachmittag weitgehend abgeriegelt pablo
sie lala wie berichtet
bis montagmorgen dürfen die 2,8
millionen bewohner lissabon nur noch aus
triftigem grund verlassen besucher nur
in ausnahmefällen einreisen
es ist nicht leicht diese maßnahme zu
ergreifen aber uns erscheint sie
unerlässlich damit die lage die in
lissabon derzeit herrscht nicht auf das
ganze land übergreift ein land das
zuletzt sogar als crooner musterschüler
galt mit einer der niedrigsten
infektionszahlen europas doch die delta
variante lässt in lissabon die werte auf
den höchsten stand seit februar
schnellen auch an geographisch anderen
ende europas sorgt die delta variante
für steigende infektionszahlen in
russland haben sich die innerhalb
weniger tage mehr als verdoppelt in
moskau wurden die em fan zonen
geschlossen und großveranstaltungen
verboten
für bestimmte berufe wurde sogar eine
impfpflicht eingeführt vor weiteren
unpopulären schritten schrecken die
behörden aber noch zurück im september
sind parlamentswahlen auf der anderen
seite entfallen mit beginn der
sommerferien weitere beschränkungen für
auslandsreisen wichtige urlaubsländer
wie frankreich und griechenland gelten
jetzt nicht mehr als risikogebiete wegen
sinkender infektionszahlen hat das lka
sie von der liste gestrichen
das gilt auch für belgien norwegen und
einzelne regionen in dänemark den
niederlanden und spanien
für die klima- aktivisten der friday ist
future bewegung endet heute eine lange
corona pause in mehr als 30 deutschen
städten gegen die demonstranten wieder
auf die straße wie hier in hamburg
exakt 100 tage vor der bundestagswahl
fordern sie die einhaltung der
klimaziele
die kundgebungen sollen jetzt wieder
jede woche stattfinden vor 80 jahren hat
nazi deutschland die sowjetunion
überfallen bundespräsident frank walter
steinmeier fordert heute anlässlich der
katastrophalen folgen geschätzt 27
millionen tote in der damaligen
sowjetunion
daran müssen wir erinnern der deutsche
krieg gegen die sowjetunion
war eine mörderische barbara niemand
hatte in diesem krieg mehr opfer zu
beklagen als die völker der damaligen
sowjetunion und doch und doch sind diese
million nicht so tief in unser
kollektives gedächtnis eingebrannt wie
ihr leid und unsere verantwortung es
fördern sagt der bundespräsident
im iran wird heute ein neuer präsident
gewählt schon davor hatte der mächtige
wächterrat aussichtsreiche
reformkandidaten von der wahl
ausgeschlossen etwa 59 millionen
wahlberechtigte sollen entscheiden wer
nachfolger wird von präsident hassan
rohan ii als favorit gilt justizchef
ebrahimi ein erz konservativer hardliner
viele iraner scheinen diesmal nicht
wählen zu gehen
aus politikverdrossenheit und
resignation umfragen melden eine geringe
wahlbeteiligung so und dann gucken uns
jetzt noch an wie heißt das wetter hier
bei uns wird morgen nach sonnigem staat
später mehr wolken und auch teils
unwetterartige gewitter das ganze bei 25
bis 36 grad und das war es in der kürze
von uns danke dass sie dabei waren ich
wünsche ihnen jetzt ein angenehm fußball
abend im zdf
[Musik]